let me ask Mike president Han that Laker
analyst here spectrum Sports Net if I
said you're starting your team klay
Thompson or draymond Green klay Thompson
okay love that kid would it but draymond
Green in today's NBA with he be guarded
of one and two a five and played you
know a couple of different positions
defensively attitude leader hit a shot
occasionally yeah he's been a little off
lately
yeah he's a hit for us more threes for
my taste but you know it's funny and
talking all these players who are coming
up to the Laker pre-draft workouts I
asked a lot of him hey what NBA player
do you want to emulate who do you think
you are a lot of them will say like the
six nine six ten guys keep saying
draymond Green because I want to say
that they do have the whole package
offense and defense I haven't noticed
that a lot lately
a lot of kids want to be him you got a
chance to take in Langella balls workout
yesterday would you describe the
atmosphere of this workout yeah it felt
like a linker playoff series really
often it's like a practice about 30 to
40 journalists there a lot of attention
obviously anything bonzo or Lakers
especially this time of year there's not
much going on it's going to garner
plenty of attention and we agile ball
apparently has not spoken to the media
since reading a statement at least six
months ago
when he came back from China and
obviously at the media curious to see
what he has to say in the current period
since then a lot of curiosity about Li
Angelo ball working out to the Lakers
one of six guys by the way at the
pre-draft situation yesterday why did
they bring him in you know you have to
take Magic Johnson at his word right now
and he was asked that by the LA Times
and he kind of stretched out his arms
and said we've got to look at everybody
and right now the Lakers do have a 25th
and the 47th pick in the draft which is
about three weeks away but you have to
also say well you know they have a
relationship with it with a brother they
definitely are familiar with the family
and maybe they want to see if this kid
could play for the team that's
point so for now I'm gonna go with what
magic said in hey we're casting a wide
net and by the way the Lakers have
indeed worked out players who have less
skill than Lee Angelo at this point yeah
we had Seth Greenberg on last hour and
he said this kid can't play in the NBA
he said if if I was still a Long Beach
State I wouldn't have recruited him to
play there yeah you know that's the
thing you have to see what the Lakers do
going forward I mean did they put the
kid on their summer league team do they
just make this a one-time thing where I
hate they look at him and they say you
know this is this is not a good fit and
by the way he started off pretty slowly
yesterday as far as shooting not a lot
of past buckets but at the end he
definitely caught fire and it started
shooting better anyway so yeah I'll tell
you what I was more surprised by his
height - he was listed at 6 foot 5 and
I'm 6 - and he and I stood on boy so
yeah so unless he's a really fast point
guard or the next step hurry and I have
to wonder where his place in the NBA
will be how secure is Alonzo balls place
on this team very secure you know I get
that question a lot we have talked to
plenty of people over there about it and
the deal is they like the player they
got they absolutely do and everyone says
well Donovan Mitchell well yeah loans
are what number two overall and Donovan
white number 13 overall a lot of teams
passed on Donovan all right and more
more people say we're not Jason Tatum
well he actually would not work out for
the Lakers because his camp apparently
thought that what the Lakers have
branded a room that's good enough for
them and the Lakers are gonna go with a
boy cart which indeed they did
Lanza definitely does need to work on
some things though all right he missed
30 games because of three different
injuries so he's got to get stronger
during the offseason also he's got to
work on some of his percentages 45
percent from the free-throw line
that will not get it done especially for
a point guard and he was only about
thirty percent from three-point range so
he's got to improve a lot of things and
also add kind of a floater he was not
real good close to the basket when he
was on the move as a rookie talking to
Mike Bresnahan who covers the Lakers
joining us Dan Patrick show we were
speculating here you know prior to the
show
and starting the show on the guys asked
me what I thought LeBron would do and I
start to survey this situation with
Houston or Philadelphia you throw in the
Bryan Colangelo caveat as well and my
god my gut feeling is LeBron may look at
the Lakers and go I don't know I want to
see where they are in a year
Philadelphia that might be a possibility
but also I get the feeling LeBron might
just say let me sign one more year in
Cleveland and then survey the situation
what do you think yeah yeah how
different deal with the landscape be if
Cleveland had lost that game 7 to
Indiana in the first round then
everything's on the table for LeBron
instead you know Paul George to me is a
guy who's more likely to be on the move
because he wondered what two playoff
games with his team whereas here we are
still talking about LeBron and we're
about to enter June so I think you know
there's a chance that LeBron stays in
Cleveland I still think he'll be on the
move I always go back to what he said
during the all-star break and NBA
Commissioner Adam Silver his annual
sit-down with reporters back in February
he said yeah you know maybe we'll take a
look at changing the playoffs
configuration since the West is always
so much better than the East maybe won't
combine the two conferences once the
postseason begins and the LeBron was
asked about it either that day or the
very next day he was like no no I love
the way things are lined up right now
he's all he knows is the east and it's
almost like an intentional walk for him
every single year to get to the finals
and we're not quite the case this year
obviously a couple game sevens already
for him you get the feeling that he will
stay in the East yeah who's going to be
with the Lakers starting next season boy
that's a great question Dan you know
obviously Paul George seemingly could be
the one to leave OKC and join the Lakers
you got the Southern California natives
you get the feeling the Lakers are going
to start courting him very actively in
about a month when free agency begins
901 p.m. Pacific time June 30th I would
not be surprised if he is on the team
LeBron seems a little bit more like a
reach right now although as everyone's
reported he does have family in LA and
he's got the at least one or two houses
out here as well
Kawhi Leonard I don't see quite as much
because I'm not sure the Lakers want to
give up their young assets at this point
so he could be also a little bit more of
a long shot but I do see Paul George and
maybe they're going to do what they did
last season signed a couple of vets to
one-year deals they give Kentavious
caldwell-pope one year and 18 million
dollars in the acquired Brook Lopez in
the last year of his contract and he was
about 23 million so if all else fails I
see them doing a bunch more one-year
deals and hey they're looking at it as a
two-year process if they don't get
anyone this summer next summer you look
at klay Thompson potentially being free
Kawhi Leonard could be free in a year a
free agent near as opposed to costing
you a lot of assets right now and also
Jimmy Butler is potentially a free agent
next July what about draft prospects for
the Lakers you know 25 is a little low
they're ecstatic to be back in the first
round they got the pick from Cleveland
as part of the Isaiah Thomas trade you
need to make them pretty wealthy in the
first round the last couple of years
last year they got Kyle Kuzma at 27 Josh
Hart became a starter by the end of the
year and he was a 30th overall pick
they're happy to be back in the first
round it doesn't seem like a real deep
draft but as we can tell they're
definitely doing a lot of due diligence
bringing in a lot of players last year
similar situation they had two
first-round picks in a sec rare pick
they brought in about a hundred players
mmm I imagine about the same number this
summer
Mike great stuff good to check in with
you glad to have you back on the program
thanks for joining us that's a Mike
Bresnahan Laker reporter analyst
spectrum Sports Net for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
you